[Musique]
les gens ils sont ils sont très fâchés
de la wii
je fais on vient sur le terrain pour
défendre notre cause notre avenir
nos enfants
[Musique]
cette bataille pour que tous les corps
soient punis
c'est un mouvement de la jeunesse fera
pas tant que nous n'aurons pas aux
éditions de route et justice
[Musique]
yanni gourde et les tensions qui
n'arrête pas ce tacle aussi aujourd'hui
par ce qu'on appelle un pays de l'or
missionary ticket une forme de vie
verrouillage carrément des activités un
verrouillage du pays à adhérer à tous
tous les secteurs de soi l'école sur la
santé soit le promets à c'est tout tout
est verrouillé
[Musique]
pays loc
c'est à dire pays bloqué lors de notre
passage à port au prince la grève
générale en est à sa cinquième semaine
depuis les premiers jours de septembre
l'odeur des pneus qui brûlent n'a pas
quitté les rues de la capitale
de pays d'oc cela signifie aussi que les
routes sont bloquées à travers le pays
les biens de première nécessité le
pétrole
le matériel médical plus rien ne circule
normalement
partout on manque de tout les jours de
manifestation seules les motos arrivent
à circuler à travers le chaos des rues
de port au prince
mais la contestation ne faiblit pas
c'est toute la population qui ne veut
plus continuer à vivre dans des
conditions inhumaines
c'est toute la population qui ne veut
plus que un petit tampon sans
s'approprier toutes les richesses du
pays pendant qu'ils sont en train de
croupir dans la crasse
c'est toute la population qui est toute
la fonction il y en a marre et qui ne
recueille lutte que moi même ou engagés
me la donnes un villa et l'isi charlier
est aux premières lignes de ce vaste
mouvement anticorruption elle est née à
montréal a passé son enfance en haïti
avant d'étudier l'administration à
l'uqam faut que nous pas des actions
concrètes pacifiquement mais il faut
qu'ils tendent insee des exigences mais
exiger justice
ce qu'on a eue après le cynisme c'est
toute cette mafia économique qui en a
profité fonctionnant télé poche encore
plus et comme c'est un des gens qui
étaient déjà dans l'administration
publique donc ils connaissent très bien
tous les couloirs de l'administration
publique
donc ils ont fait que perpétuer cette
pratique d'impunité de commission que
nous avons en haïti et qui remonte
vraiment à près de 200 ans
[Musique]
le séisme du 12 janvier 2010 a été un
des plus grande catastrophe humanitaire
de l'histoire 280 mille morts et 300
mille blessés en quelques minutes
plusieurs ont vu naître dans cette
catastrophe l'espoir de reconstruire
haïti sur des bases nouvelles
nous voici aujourd'hui répondre à un
nouveau rendez vous pour transformer les
décombres laissés par le séisme du 12
janvier en un vaste chantier de
reconstruction et leurs fondations de la
nation haïtienne
il ne reste rien ce rêve l'aide massive
internationales dont celle du canada est
venu surtout par le biais des ong qui
ont déferlé sur est ici pour s'occuper
des besoins des plus criant
le gouvernement haïtien lui bénéficiait
d'un fonds propres de 3 milliards de
dollars constitué à partir d'une aide
venue du venezuela de fonds petro caribe
le président vénézuélien hugo chavez
avait offert à plusieurs pays des
caraïbes haïti d'acheter du pétrole a
pris des secondes d'engranger les
profits de la vente d'essence à la
population et de rembourser dans 25 ans
cet argent devait être dédiée au
développement
c'est la dilapidation patente de ce
fonds de plusieurs milliards qui va
faire sauter le couvercle de la patience
et issia et créer ce qu'on appelle le
mouvement des pétro challenger
[Musique]
quand on a vu cet argent là se faire me
lapider que ce soit dans les pays que ce
soit dans un auto que ce soit dans des
bateaux que ce soit dans des projets
personnels à travers le pays dont des
sénateurs des députés ou des membres
très proches du pouvoir
donc là c'est un homme face et là
gilbert mirambeau producteur et
scénariste a été le premier petrucciani
joueurs donc ça me donnait tout un
cocktail pour que les gens disent vous
savez quoi
on en veut plus ce système ce ras-le-bol
se réveille après naissance un matin
d'été 2018 à montréal où vivaient alors
gilbert me rends au je me suis réveillé
leur 4,5 à mano j'attendais ma soeur je
dis faut que je le fasse une photo il
publie cette photo sur twitter une
question qu comme petro caribe à où est
passé l'argent de petrocaribe est une
question slogan qu'on retrouve 18 mois
plus tard encore frappé sur les murs de
port-au-prince
j'ai vu que mon téléphone a commencé à
exploser
puis trois jours plus tard devenu viral
gilbert mirambeau revient en haïti le
mouvement petro challenger fait boule de
neige dans un pays déjà survoltée par
l'augmentation brutale du prix de
l'essence d'une inflation généralisée
une trentaine de jeunes se mobilisent
autour du tweet de gilbert mirambeau
pour former le groupe new pape domi nous
ne dormons pas manifestations sit in ils
vont forcer la main des juges de la cour
supérieure des comptes qui selon eux
tardent à publier les conclusions d'une
vaste enquête sur ce fond quand on a
fait pression qu'on a exigé qu'ils nous
donnent
le rapport sur la gestion des fonds
d'être arrivé on a eu dix ans de gorgon
stage de dix ans de dilapidation dix ans
de corruption et parler comme ça au vu
et au su de tous c'est sûr qu'ils
allaient beaucoup de rumeurs on s'en
doutait deux rapports successifs sont
autant de bombes le gaspillage de ce
fonds petrocaribe et qui devait servir
au développement est évident - s'était
fait le système de corruption
généralisée et mise en lumière de 2008 à
2018 sous quatre présidences et six
gouvernements c'est du pareil au même
même l'actuel président je venais de
moïse est épinglée pour un stratagème
daté d'avant sa présidence alors qu'il
était un homme d'affaires et que deux de
ses compagnons signé deux contrats
presque identique pour la même
construction d'une même route deux
entreprises ont eu même numéro fiscal
numéro de fax et ont reçu de l'argent
pour faire le même projet le rapport ne
mâche pas ses mots il y a eu collusion
favoritisme ce n'est ni plus ni moins
qu'un stratagème de détournement de
fonds basée sur ça un corrompu ne peut
pas diriger une nation c'est aussi
simple que ça le président annie avoir
perçu l'argent découlant de ces contrats
mais jusqu'ici aucune procédure
judiciaire n'a permis d'y voir clair
[Musique]
la démission du président moïse est
devenu le premier slogan de la
contestation nationale
mais pour ces jeunes qu'il faut aller
bien plus loin ils veulent changer le
système
une classe politique qui a
institutionnalisé généralisée et mis en
place des mécanismes de corruption et
l'impunité et qui n'est pas non plus
innocente et non plus 10 note de tout ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui pascal soulage
journaliste et militante féministe c'est
quand même si gouvernement et c'est
quand même le président préval ses prix
versé martelly et ses essais après j'en
ai mises aujourd'hui gilbert mirambeau
et producteur il écrit des comédies faut
dit-il lui c'est patrick c c'est le fils
du sénateur il est un peu magané et
quelques petits courts durant la
première session de tournage
il planche sur son prochain film mal à
chiang satire de la société haïtienne
le fils d'un sénateur est kidnappé par
leurs ravisseurs malchanceux qui se
retrouvent malgré eux au coeur d'un
mystérieux complot ou se révèle toute la
déchéance du système politique
[Musique]
en haïti se faire élire c'est un moyen
de s'enrichir
personne n'a encore été condamnés aucun
procès n'a été fait l'avocat samuel
madistin qui a déjà siégé comme sénateur
dirige aujourd'hui la fondation jeu
claires une ong qui lutte contre la
corruption politique
vous pouvez avoir quelqu'un qui habite
chez vous à côté de chez vous qui ne
peut pas acheter une bicyclette mais qui
est beaucoup mais qui a ému de sa
communauté qui est élu député
un an plus tard eh bien il peut
constituer deux trois immeubles ou 1
millions de dollars ou 6 cents mille
dollars et doit tout l'unité
personne ne dit rien des enjeux mettre
fin à l'immunité qui protège les élus de
toute poursuite
ce soit des gens justement qui bénéficie
de l'immunité soit de l'immunité
parlementaire soit de l'immunité conte
président de la république ou bien comme
ministre comme directeur général et nous
avons demandé à ce que les immunités
tombe devant la lutte contre la
corruption
[Musique]
ils font des propositions bateau il faut
des propulsions gilbert chéri est une
des victimes de cette catastrophe
économique
il a travaillé comme chauffeur pendant
des années depuis sept ans il est au
chômage
comme la moitié des haïtiens comment
demander aux gens de rester chez eux
pour ne pas manifester quand la jeunesse
pierre confiance dans l'avenir
ces gens là quand ils ont terminé les
études classiques les études
universitaires ils ont obligé de laisser
le pays tout sur l'inde au canada aux
états unis au chili
voici tu avais du travail et donc de
l'argent qu'est-ce que ça change
je vais envoyer mon garçon à
l'université
et je mène une vie oui mais que c'est le
pays le plus pauvre de l'hémisphère de
50 à 70% chômage la majorité vit avec
moins de trois dollars canadiens par
jour alors que les prix ne cessent
d'augmenter
mais le soulèvement a déjà formation
c'est déjà pas mal
sa promesse ces gens là n'ont pas accès
aux soins utiles et ces gens là n'ont
pas accès à l'eau potable
ces gens n'ont pas accès au logement
mais le 6 millions d'haïtiens vivent au
seuil de pauvreté
à moins de 2 dollars 41 par jour
plus le sait millions haïssent ils
vivent au seuil de pauvreté extrême
est ce qu'on peut vivre comme ça
[Musique]
dimanche matin l'état-major de nouveau
apte au mit c'est une réunion
stratégique
il prépare une manifestation prévue dans
deux jours ce sont des jeunes
professionnelle des diplômés souvent
formés à l'étranger des artistes ils ne
se connaissaient pas forcément avant la
naissance de leur mouvement
ils se sont réunis autour d'une
indignation partagée en général
moi j'ai quand même 32 ans c'est à dire
je sais la génération ans moi c'est la
génération qui doit agir gueule
bien-aimée féministe et qu'au médium
mais pour des raisons je pense
d'éducation tu vois nos parents étaient
des gens
qui ont grandi sur la dictature je pense
qu'il ya un rapport avec la politique
très de retenue et il ya énormément il
ya énormément de personnes de mon âge à
ne pas vouloir s'impliquer à ne pas
pouvoir ne pas vouloir investir l'espace
politique parce qu'en fait il ya une
image très glauque hissel choses
traînent brumeuse autour de la politique
qui fait que tu as peur malgré tout
disons les deux pieds dans la politique
oui où oovoo voté sous php cap laisse au
pouvoir l'approcher privilège de monter
nos médias mais chaque et en chaire et
ils ont investi massivement les réseaux
sociaux tout mot des pratiques qui lag
et nos côtés nous il a gaspillé à nous
voler l'argent donc innocent paillot
projet société les médias traditionnels
des invits il représente le renouveau
politique mais qui ouvre une émotion
il
james betis est un des leaders du groupe
nous lui avons demandé pour notre
entretien de choisir un lieu qui
symbolise ce qui ne marche pas d'un pays
je viens ici c'est parce que au moins en
haïti l'éducation c'est un problème
majeur
si on dit qu et les font plutôt qu'à et
b et dans le cadre d'un prêt que l'état
haïtien fait pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des citoyens haïtiens
et s'il ya un problème majeur dans la
société haïtienne c'est lui c'est le
problème d'éducation
nous sommes dans un dc public comme tous
les autres il est fermé depuis cinq
semaines à cause de la grève générale
même s'il s'agit d'une école publique y
inscrire ses enfants
c'est ici du privilège en fait nous
avons en haïti et 80 2 % des écoles sont
des écoles privées et le reste est
l'état il ya une craig de man pollet
c'est quoi le public
mais il ya aussi des contacts qu'il faut
faire au niveau du système éducatif des
officiels des députés pour avoir une
place dans les lycées et ça c'est très
payant faisait quand même pour aller à
l'école publique il ya peu de corruption
ou de politique molia tout ça et parce
qu'il ya en a certains qui arrivent à
trouver une place dans les lycées ils
passent pas normalement par le chemin
tracé par par l'administration de
l'école en fait ils utilisent soit un
député ou
un confesseur ont un directeur d'école
c'est de la course sans quoi la zone
économique petrocaribe et l'arrivée d'un
nouveau président en 2011 michel
martelly créé l'espoir qu'il sera faire
bon usage du fonds petrocaribe est le
seul sous responsabilité haïtienne j'ai
eu de grands projets construction
l'école car a su quelques cantines
populaires et aux et habille nos deux
pays
des kits pour aider et planteurs qui
pourrait des agriculteurs quittent plus
et des mondes qui n'a conditions
difficiles
c'est une image d'un pays moderne une
petite suisse des caraïbes que l'on
croit apercevoir à travers ses photos
tirées d'un bilan officiel du fonds
petro caribe
sur le terrain c'est une autre imac
pour chaque projet conti complété
plusieurs font l'objet de blâme pour
retard coûts excessifs mauvaise gestion
comptable ou contrazy régulier une foule
d'autres chantiers restent en plan faute
de fonds comme ce projet de viaduc dans
la commune de carrefour
le contrat d'exécution de quelque 18
millions de dollars canadiens a été
signé en décembre 2012
les travaux devaient durer 18 mois ils
ont été arrêtés
cinq ans plus tard
[Musique]
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
un autre monument c'est le marché de
fontamara dans le quartier de martissant
et travaux 8 millions de dollars ou 6
abandonné au total des centaines de
millions de dollars évaporés dont on a
perdu toute trace
deux séismes puis les ouragans samedi et
matthew sont autant d'occasions de
suspendre le processus d'attribution des
contrats par appel d'offres ils seront
donnés de gré à gré au nom de l'état
d'urgence
l'urgence a même été invoqué pour donner
des contrats d'amélioration de terrain
sportif et de pose de gazon synthétique
au moment où les enquêteurs se sont
rendus sur plusieurs de ces terrains ils
les ont trouvés inondée à la moindre
pluie faute de drainage
ouf il est déchiré et sans trace du
fameux gazon synthétique
un programme qui avait coûté plus de 13
millions
[Musique]
et toi caribe contre carmaux aux
scandales financiers dans le pays c'est
horrible ça se voit c'est là pour lâcher
les rapports techniques fait pas des
vérificateurs des auditeurs de la coupe
donc c'est vraiment une première que la
lutte contre la corruption
[Musique]
je pense que ce sens aux malouines
peut-être les effets de quelques sans
abri parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants
des rues kitsch dormir le soir etc on
peut leur abril moi c'est leur maison
sur le champ-de-mars pas ce soir ils
dorment là aucun du 7 mars
sae domicile
l'économiste emmanuel hadoux lyon nous
fait visiter un autre des multiples
symboles des échecs de la reconstruction
de théâtre rex était une véritable
institution culturelle pour des
générations d'haïtiens
on devait de reconstruire on se
contentera de peindre sa façade au cour
invraisemblable de 300 mille dollars
soit l'envoi régulier pourquoi parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'efforts pour
faire semblant pour montrer qu'on a
donnée de faire des choses en on paie
une façade de semer la poudreuse de
montrer ou non lieu de changer les
choses
c'était vraiment fort
[Musique]
payer plus ce militant qui déjà a
présenté hier scandé des propos aussi la
bri de public là des paroles et rimes en
boucle toute activité aux paralysés ou
pas
la position d usage de gaz lacrymogènes
y par sont pas capables
il faut là ils veulent la démission du
président mais aussi une véritable
reddition qu'on mégaprocès aujourd'hui
nous on demande ce qui s'est passé et on
demande justement que ce qui doit être
sanctionné soit sanctionné ce qui doit
être clarifiée soient clarifiées et que
nous on puisse repartir sur de nouvelles
bases
c'est non négociable shannon ville
obligé constitué aux seins de force de
pression et en particulier nous pas
compris ce qui s'est un peu partout dans
des quartiers au sein d'organismes des
regroupements citoyens de petro
challengers se sont formés comme ceux ci
qui se sont nommés nous pape complices
ne seront pas complices les citoyens se
sont rendus compte que c'était une vaste
opération vraiment de voler c'est en ce
sens que nous autres nous nous
combattons pour que ces veaux le lacet
dilapidateurs la soie que la justice
face au ghana en octobre des dizaines de
milliers de manifestants ont répondu à
un appel des artistes
nous allons pas les civils mais
policiers des enseignants des
professionnels de la santé
le clergé ont chacun tenu leur
manifestation je pense que la plupart
des secteurs organisé de cette société
dont le milieu d'affaires souhaite voir
les choses changer le milieu des
affaires magnitude conservateur emboîte
le pas dit le banquier bernard cran qui
a tenu plusieurs rencontres avec les
jeunes petro challenge un mois je
souhaite le départ de jovenna luis je
souhaite son départ mais de façon
coordonnée que ce soit n'est pas
ordonner ce en revanche mais sans
impunité
oui nous voulons avancer un chef d'état
et je suis sûr que nous finirons par le
faire
l'avocat andré michel ex candidat à la
présidence a longtemps dénoncé la
culture de la corruption
il est une des principales figures de
l'opposition
il appelle ouvertement au soulèvement
oui nous voulons casser un système
d'exclusion et qui a laissé au bord du
chemin les jeunes les femmes
le paysan mais on ne veut pas à lever à
une situation de chaos c'est parce que
nous recherchons
[Musique]
quoi qu'il en soit dans ce paisible
chaos est une condition quotidienne la
frontière entre la normalité et
l'explosion sociale et bien n'est-ce
[Musique]
combien de temps peut durer cette crise
qui conduit le pays au seuil de
l'anarchie quand on traverse et dans le
nord de l'artibonite au niveau du sud
asie la ville des cayes
le peuple est un étang l'insurrection en
fait par exemple aux gonaïves les gens
ils circulent
ils manifestent et avec avec des armes
de guerre l'insurrection mais aussi
banditisme et guerre de gagne
sur les routes de kidnapping et le
rançonnage son nom est courant à la
faveur des manifs des commerces sont
incendiés ou pillés
[Musique]
l'organisme de droits humains en haïti
le rndh recense la mort de 233 personnes
depuis juillet 2018
des morts qu'on attribue à
l'intervention des autorités mais qui
sont aussi souvent le résultat de
règlements de comptes entre factions
rivales
la violence politique par les armes est
endémique en haïti en septembre au
milieu de ce chaos
un sénateur sort son pistolet devant des
manifestants et tire à l'aveuglette
laissant un photographe de presse
je n'aime pas jouer au catastrophiste et
aux prophètes de malheur mais
malheureusement je pense que ça va mal
se passer si ça ne changera c'est une
situation qui peut déboucher sur
beaucoup de violence notre travail pour
que la peau retournée 15 octobre partout
dans le pays on écoute le président
moïse en conférence de presse
faire une de ses très rares apparitions
il déclare qu'il reste en poste nous
demander pour démissionner est ce qu'on
attendait mais sogno ou pas là toujours
pareil pour nous monter à l'excès
copernic a dit bayou
[Musique]
l'aviation
il n'en faut pas plus pour déclencher de
nouvelles manifestations spontanées
qu'est ce qui fait que aujourd'hui joël
moïse s'accroche au pouvoir
c'est la peur de faire face à la rigueur
de la justice qui pose mais ce jour de
la mise à s'accrocher au pouvoir en
dépit du fait qu'il est évident que je
faisais le brise de gouverner plus mais
ils s'approchent pour pouvoir parce que
le pouvoir représente pour lui une sorte
de bâche de protection
le président joël moïse ne dirige plus
rien at il même confiance en sa propre
police
[Musique]
le 17 octobre lorsqu'il doit sortir pour
une fonction protocolaire des agents de
sécurité étrangers privés sont filmés
montant la garde depuis une tour
avoisinantes
ce qui renforce l'idée que geoff hann
moïse doit sa survie politique au
soutien de la communauté internationale
aux états unis en particulier
[Musique]
j'espère surtout que la communauté
internationale qui continue de supporter
jordan morize finira par comprendre que
la communauté internationale n'a pas le
droit de continuer à supporter un chef
d'état rejeté par la population
le consensus social contre la corruption
est désormais telle que toute la classe
politique s'en réclament je veux y
compris de vieux routiers de la
politique haïtienne comme le sénateur
youri latortue un des principaux
adversaires politiques du président
moïse
voilà comment se fait la loi en haïti
dit dès que le moteur dépasse un million
$ il faut ouverture des plis
il faut faire appel à toute compagnie
qui peuvent offrir une meilleure offre
et ceci n'a jamais été fait et c'est
comme ça vous allez voir tous les
contrats de vie dure albi à part à part
peut-être deux ou trois sur 300 contrats
tous les contrats sociaux gré à gré
c'est signé entre eux des personnes qui
à rothau donne de l'argent à cash de
sénateur latortue incarne bien les
contradictions de la politique haïtienne
on surnomme monsieur 30% en référence à
la commission qu'on l'accuse de
percevoir pour des contrats
gouvernementaux
il ya des gens qui écrivent à votre
sujet et qu'ils disent c'est monsieur
30% vous avez déjà entendu ça oui j'ai
entendu c'est ce que vous leur répondez
écoutez il ya des tribunaux
il y a il ya des institutions
il va vous rirez inquiète à bruxelles
ils doivent le faire s'ils ont des
preuves mais jusqu'à présent il parle
dans les réseaux sociaux moi j'attends
cette réputation ne l'a pas empêché en
2016 de présider la commission éthique
et anti corruption du sénat et de
produire un premier rapport sur le
scandale des troquets ribes et parce que
vous considérez aujourd'hui un peu trop
challenger moi je sais je suis pas un
pet routya ledger dans le sas de petro
challengers sont les jeunes qui sont
venus soutenir mon rapport mais moi je
veux dire en fin de compte
j'appuie la pirouette challenger puisque
ils seront les jeunes qui cholet réseaux
sociaux aux antilles où elle a rouvert
depuis trop cagibi n'est jamais trop
challengers doivent composer avec un
succès qui les dépasse ils ont beaucoup
de compagnons de route
tout le monde y compris les partis
politiques traditionnels appelle
aujourd'hui à manifester
c'est exactement ce contre quoi on se
bat la bataille pour avoir le procès
fait trop calibré pour tracer l'exode
c'est pas une bataille pour donner un
endroit aux gens pour venir
le sénateur latortue se dit prêt à se
mettre en retrait si le président
démissionne novembre à se retrouver dans
la tradition on va occuper le poste dans
les temps au contraire j'ai mis mon
mandat sur la table et encore
démissionné du sénat pour pouvoir
laisser la transition faire les
changements nécessaires
le groupe new pape demi c'est qu'il se
trouve à la croisée des chemins
ils discutent aujourd'hui de la
transition advenant le départ souhaité
du président il ya plusieurs groupes qui
se positionnent comme des alternatives
pour faire cette transition il ya aussi
une autre alternative c'est vous c'est
la jeunesse une jeunesse qui a fait son
chemin jusqu'au congrès américain en
décembre et sa boîte au cours du
week-end à auxerre 2 0
la mine qui n'ont pas envie de sur la
politique
il y en a formé à c'est le moment il
faut y aller mais c'est très compliqué
déjà deux mots tu as you go sur la
politique et ça ça me fait très peur
parce que
il faut que non il faut investir
l'espace pour le tueur il faut venir
avec cette nouvelle manière de faire de
la politique
quelque chose qui soit clim je sais que
les poules cette apologie de crime nulle
part
moi je suppose que le mouvement n'est
pas beau me devient un mouvement au
niveau national et je fais beaucoup
d'efforts pour ça pour moi mon travail
au niveau de nouveau mais c'est de faire
en sorte que le mouvement devient un
mouvement citoyen mouvements de jeunes
et un mouvement qui peut lui venir un
jour une force politique qui peut
orienter la politique haïtienne
est-ce qu'on peut revenir en arrière
vous croyez non non c'est pas contre ces
vols
on ne peut pas revenir en agace vraiment
belga le 27 octobre
ça chauffait devant l'ambassade du
canada au mât chinois qui elles mêmes en
a complètement brûlé défunt l'ambassade
du canada
un cocktail molotov a été lancé sur le
terrain de la mission canadienne et des
pneus ou tête incendie devant le portail
pendant les manifestations qui tout
l'automne ont paralysé haïti nous avons
été frappés par l'expression d'une
colère contre la communauté
internationale
pourquoi le canada était de cibler
[Musique]
aujourd'hui à la vérité et sur les pages
ou venelles et qui représente
l'adversaire pour la population c'est la
communauté internationale qui est
supporter journal brise pour l'avocat
andré michel c'est aux haïtiens de
régler la crise politique
mais là on parle devant l'ambassade du
canada à la barre elle est cadencée
souci de cannes a aussi le souci à la
vérité ici en haïti et ce sont les
américains contrôlent vraiment la
situation
mais attention le canada a aussi à pois
la france a également un point important
[Musique]
chaque jour les amateurs de joutes
politiques se retrouvent au champ de
mars au centre de la capitale pour
débattre à cause de notre présence la
discussion s'oriente tout de suite sur
le canada est aussi sur le corps gros
une entité pratiquement inconnu chez
nous mais dont tout le monde parle en
haïti et qui a pivoté soi-disant les
tailles sont bien gouvernement ce coco
est formée de représentants de quelques
pays dont les etats-unis la france et le
canada de même que de l'union européenne
de l'organisation des états américains
et des nations unies pour un grand
nombre d'haïtiens ce groupe exerce ni
plus ni moins qu'une tutelle sur leur
pays
pour la population pour le citoyen sur
les ambassadeurs du corps gros qui
représente cette barre de protection
inacceptable pour un chef d'état
corrompus et qu'ils paient dans
plusieurs dossiers de corruption et de
surcroît rejeté par la population les
bases de ce groupe sont jetés en janvier
2003 au cours d'une réunion discrète
aucune image d'infiltrer obtenus dans le
parc de la gatineau au québec plus
précisément au lac meech
j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette espèce de
remue méninges avec de la france l'union
européenne la francophonie
internationale les états unis
l'organisation des états américains
foire est une espèce de câbles ou le
qu'est ce qu'on peut
haïti est alors en quasi-guerre civile
des milices paramilitaires de
l'opposition et des groupes armés
fidèles au président jean bertrand
aristide s'affrontent
l'ancien secrétaire d'état du canada
pour l'amérique latine et les caraïbes
denis paradis avait reçu le mandat du
premier ministre chrétien d'organiser
cette rencontre spéciale de deux jours
baptisé initiative d'ottawa sur haïti
est ce que il y avait des représentats
ici donc après deux représentants
haïtiens est strictement quelques pays
qu'ils émanent et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
nouveau les aider mais avait pas de
reprise avant ici et pour cause la
suspension de la souveraineté du pays
était sur la table
non juste et sérieux en parlait de plus
ni plus ni moins que meta it siens
tutelle non on évite ces mots leur
apprend ainsi que bien sûr c'est pas de
ma taille ici en tutelle c'était c'était
davantage
est ce que la souveraineté des états est
un principe immuable
de toute évidence la réponse est non du
moins en ce qui concerne haïti
un an après ce remue-ménage au canada en
février 2004 des forces spéciales
américaines débarquent à port au prince
pendant que des soldats canadiens
sécurisé l'aéroport en présence des
ambassadeurs des états unis et de la
france
le président aristide signent une lettre
de démission est un transportés vers la
république centrafricaine le président
en sa résidence voit des soldats blancs
débarquer ce que nous n'avons pas en
haïti la nuit et ils l'ont forcé manu
militari à rentrer dans un avion un
avion tout de blanc sans aucun signe
déçu finalement après on a vu les images
de cet avion qui sont qui est parti avec
le président restait de son épouse jean
sainvil milite au sein de solidarité
québec haïti qui demande au canada de
couper tout lien avec le président
haïtien jouvenel moïse deux groupes a
occupé le bureau électoral de justin
trudeau en septembre avant les haïtiens
voyait le canada comme étant un
partenaire avec qui on pouvait parler à
faire et il n'y avait jamais cette
perception qui pourrait y avoir une
tentation de contrôle de mes mises
d'impérialisme etc
impérialisme ou non les nations unies
élabore à cette époque un nouveau
principe du droit international la
responsabilité de protéger les
populations et dès le lendemain du
départ d'aristide
le conseil de sécurité des belges des
casques bleus en haïti pour assurer la
stabilité du pays
ils sont restés pendant 15 années de
2004 à 2010 9
l'onu a été considérée par beaucoup
d'haïtiens comme une force d'occupation
par l'impression d'avoir fait un coup
d'état n'est pas tout
les gens ne comprennent pas ce que ça
signifie pour un noir d'entendre ou des
blancs se réunir et pour dire que vous
représentez une bombe qu'il faut
désamorcer avec le séisme de 2010 et la
vague de l'aide internationale des
ambassades du corps gros vont devenir
omniprésente en haïti gilles rivard
ambassadeur du canada à cette époque
quand j'étais ambassadeur j'ai rencontré
le président préval aux quatre fois par
mois pour tous parlent de toutes sortes
de choses
une proximité qui a selon lui entraîner
une fausse perception et beaucoup
d'haïtiens qui ont peut-être
l'impression que tu un espèce de
gouvernement parallèle
j'ai pas du tout ça le croire groupe
status simplement une structure pour
permettre une meilleure coordination
entre les différentes institutions
présentent un étui principal l'aide
humanitaire c'est une chose mais il ya
aussi des intérêts stratégiques
l'actuel président moïse fait certes bon
ménage avec les grandes puissances en
haïti était parmi les pays est confiée
par justin trudeau au sommet du g7 de
charlevoix
cette relation privilégiée a aussi une
contrepartie diplomatique haïti avait
une relation privilégiée avec le
venezuela
aujourd'hui je suis avec mon frère le
président madour et pourtant en 2019
le président moïse s'est rangé derrière
les états unis et le canada pour tourner
le dos au président maduro du venezuela
arrêté
reste à voir si cette fidélité ou core
group pourra sauver sa présidence